I love being a mommy I love my kids so I
just stand well Angelina Jolie might be
staying at home with the kids but her ex
just made a pit stop pit like Brad Pitt
yep
the Oscar winner was just spotted at
Angie's home for the first time since
their high-profile breakup in 2016 it's
real exciting the 56 year old was
snapped on his motorcycle riding away
from his ex-wife's home in Los Feliz
after a two-hour visit last week the
sighting came just days after Angie
opened up to Vogue India about their
split saying that the divorce was
largely for the sake of her and Brad six
children quote I separated for the
well-being of my family it was the right
decision I continue to focus on their
healing some have taken advantage of my
silence and the children see lies about
themselves in the media but I remind
them that they know their own truth we
and your children are your best friends
is kind of a it's a nice life Brad and
Angelina tied the knot in 2014 and
called it quits two years later
Angie citing irreconcilable differences
as the reason for their divorce but now
a source tells ET the two have come a
very long way and they're finally in a
place where they both want to work
together to raise their kids
this source revealed that the visit
wasn't the first time that brad has
spent time with Angie in her home adding
that while they have no plans to
reconcile their relationship is amicable
and they chose to live close to one
another so they could easily go back and
forth with the kids you know we want to
make it a family affair ET source
explained that when the couple first
split their only communication was
through their attorneys quote they
literally couldn't bear to even speak to
one another now the source says they are
on the same page and want their kids to
be healthy and happy and to have the
support of both of their parents quote
it has taken years to heal and they
finally are in a place where they can
co-parent in a really healthy way